and tonight we continue to honor the
amazing life legacy
of radio legend rush limbaugh yep you
got it his longtime producer
call screener he did his own show behind
the show
our friend james golden aka bo snurly
will be here tonight
andrew cuomo nursing home scandal the
governor is now reportedly facing
a federal and state investigation into
a criminal activity and what might
appear to be a massive cover
cover-up senator ted cruz under fire
today is here to respond to the
criticism
surrounding his recent flight to cancun
to drop off his daughters for a trip
with their friends
and yes turn around and come right back
home and he arrived home in houston
already
and here's what he told reporters
earlier outside of his home
last 24 story and a bit of a twitter
sensation
that i went with my family traveled
yesterday to mexico
i just got back i flew out last late
last night
we had spent two days without power
and my girls wanted to take a trip
with their friends and frankly get
somewhere
where it was warmer and heidi and i
agreed we took them i flew them down
last night and then i just flew back
today
you actually can be a father and senator
at the same time
senator cruz will join us live from
texas tonight protesters are outside of
his home
that is all coming up but first the
hysteria on the left is apparently never
ending
president trump now has been out of
office for nearly a month
democrats are still obsessed
with hating all things donald trump well
president trump seems to live
in their sick brains 24 7
as they cannot give up their drug of
choice
which is hatred and rage of all things
donald trump and his family
one congresswoman just introduced get
this a bill to ban
former presidents who have been
impeached twice from
getting buried at arlington national
cemetery
and of course conviction in the senate
that wouldn't be required just the
impeachment part
and meanwhile another democrat is
sponsoring legislation
that would ban president trump from
stepping foot in the u.s capitol
ever again okay and that's not all
democrats are also seeking a ban
that would block donald trump's name
from being used on any federal building
any monument
even park benches and they're also
attempting to block his
federal pension paid staff and office
space
now in the midst of a global pandemic
let me ask all of you
millions of americans are unable to get
the covert vaccine
incompetent governors botching the
rollout
millions and millions of americans out
of work
high paying career jobs literally
ripped away and destroying the energy
sector in this country
and this is what your democratic leaders
and lawmakers are focused on also
those two thousand dollar checks you
know the ones they promised you before
the election
yeah they're nowhere to be found and of
course the mob the media
they don't seem to care they're also too
busy obsessively
raging 24 7 against donald trump
the movie well they just can't seem to
quit him can they
here's just one small recent example
are we done in this for a second right
again i never i never say stuff like
this but control room can we play it
again
there it is you know i've heard um from
from folks when i'm you know firing off
tweets about trump telling me to shut up
about it we should just
be quiet not talk about him anymore and
i understand that point of view
everybody wants to move on
i wish we could just kind of blow up uh
all the trump buildings like that with
nobody in them and just kind of erase
them from our memory and
men in black style but like we can't i
think i'm going to start a daily count
how many times does msdnc and fake news
cnn mention
donald trump every single day anyway the
very
liberal i'm not tim russert over at mb
is
vitriol to the good people of texas here
they are in the midst of
their winter storm power outages of
millions
subfreezing temperatures and he says
well
hey at least they're now wearing
their masks take a look let's get a
check now speaking of weather
on all of this breaking weather news
extreme winter weather slamming more
than half the country
it's killed at least 28 people across
the southeast in texas the state power
grid is
overloaded it's left at least four
million people to face historically low
temperatures without electricity
and often without heat my colleague
morgan chesky joins us now from dallas
and morgan about the only
the only upside here is i assume the
cold weather motivates people to wear a
mask
because it's one extra layer on your
face
but how bad is it morgan
it's bad chuck uh
wow also as per usual washed up actor
singer bette midler
well she took it a step further she
claimed the winter storm
was revenge because quote god
doesn't seem to like ted cruz or john
cornyn
pretty disgusting even by her
repulsively low
life standards that she has so to chucky
todd and
bette midler no do they know that people
died in this storm and
texans are suffering and older people
shivering in their homes have they
figured that out yet
now of course many on the left are
currently vilifying ted cruz today
for flying his family to cancun and back
senator cruz dropping off his daughters
for a trip with their friends
he's right back in texas now i do have
first-hand information on this that i'll
share in a moment
but you know that new guy oh that's
right this morning he decided to take a
snow day
the guy ultimately in charge of fema and
all the country's emergency resources
and federal agencies yeah he took a day
off
in the middle of this natural disaster
where's the
feign phony selective liberal outrage on
this i guess
you know to be fair it's not even really
totally clear that
joe even fully understands what's going
on in texas
during a town hall this week joe seemed
very confused about a lot of things
at one point he said there was no
vaccine when he
the biggest thing though is you remember
when you and i i shouldn't say it that
way as you remember but
when you and i talked last we talked
about it's one thing that the vaccine
which we didn't have when we came into
office but a vaccinator
how do you get the vaccine into
someone's arm
uh joe when you took office
there are about a million one million
not 300
1 million vaccines under trump's
operation warp speed going into the arms
of americans
every single day a million a day 1
million not 300 over the summer 1
million
that was happening before you were sworn
in in fact
yeah that video right there of joe biden
he's getting the vaccine that was before
christmas
that was in december uh jody
remember remember well case not here's a
friendly reminder
you just go ahead anytime you're ready
i'm doing this to demonstrate that
people should be prepared when it's
available to take the vaccine there's
nothing to worry about
i'm looking forward to the second shot
so is jill she's had her shot
earlier today she loves shots i know
you know the mob the media they they get
the vapors oh
they get the snowflakes begin to melt
they get oh
so outraged and oh they can't take it
and so
frail they they wig out every time i say
yeah joe biden looks pretty frail weak
and he's obviously cognitively
struggling but his behavior
during his rare public appearances are
troubling
he struggles with numbers twice in one
speech last week
he laid out a goal promising that they
will have
vaccinated 300 americans
he didn't say it once he said it twice
300
he also struggles with names and dates
and times
and even our declaration of independence
doesn't seem to know where he is at
times
this is something he jokingly okay
admitted during the town hall take a
look
over the years over your career you've
already spent a great deal of time at
1600 pennsylvania avenue
except now you're living there and
you're president it's been four weeks
what's it like how's it different
i get up in the morning look at jill and
say where the hell are we
no now joe you're at the white house
you're likely asleep i'm sure you had
your warm milk after your afternoon
nappy
and your day off and i assume you're
fast asleep by now but when you wake up
in the morning i hope somebody will
remind you
that you're at the white house and
you're the president of the united
states of america
in name only at least that is what your
business card probably says
and maybe you need i don't know hourly
reminders
and the radical far left climate
socialist in your party
you know the ones that are setting your
agenda would be very nice of them if
they could remind you on a fairly
regular basis
now of course this would include
policies surrounding immigration
let me predict here and now joe biden's
immigration policies
will be a colossal failure it will
harm american workers in a huge way
we'll have more people than jobs
available driving wages
down dramatically democratic lawmakers
are now
working on legislation that would give
amnesty
to what may eventually be 20 million
illegal immigrants
including those who have previously left
the country you know why
because joe's going to invite them back
now if biden gets his way
they will all become eligible for an
expedited pathway to citizenship
with a green card and citizenship even
in some cases in three years
democrats are also trying to expand the
archaic lotto
system and bring that back which would
allow even more immigrants
from all over the world into the country
based on a
random lotto drawing i wonder are we
going to make sure that people can
provide for themselves
when they get here will there be any
health check are there going to be any
background checks to make sure that
people well i don't care where you come
from but make sure anybody from any part
of the world doesn't have radical
associations
now keep in mind the biden
administration has already halted
border wall construction they have
reintroduced that policy you know the
one known as catch and release
where illegal immigrants detained at the
border
are then released right there into your
towns in your cities
many without a cova test and likely not
wearing their mask
the radical socialist democrats are now
running our federal government
buckle up i hope you get involved i hope
you get engaged
because it's going to be rocky the
impact will be felt for generations